joining us now is tulsi gabbard former
2020 democratic presidential candidate
and former hawaii congresswoman tulsi um
uh the number we've approved for ukraine
weapons and aid is is 70 billion so i
said seven that's wishful thinking so
americans are seeing their finances
hollowed out here at home
as we ship billions abroad
and the war looks like it's going in the
wrong direction
how do we reach any conclusion except
this is the ongoing humiliation of
america in our foreign policy once again
uh well laura you're you're bringing up
such critical points here that the
american people need to understand the
seriousness of the situation that the
biden administration and leaders in
washington have put us in so we go
beyond kind of the day-to-day battle
updates of what's happening in our proxy
war against russia in ukraine and
actually take a step back and focus on
the big picture in the great threat that
we face which is the reality that this
war is continuing to escalate
president biden himself says he has no
idea when or how it's going to end
but we know where this escalation leads
it leads us closer and closer
to the brink of a nuclear war with
russia
we just saw the other day in new york
city i'm sure you saw how they put out a
psa telling residents of new york city
hey here's what you do in the event of a
nuclear attack
go inside
stay inside and stay tuned i almost fell
out of my chair when i saw that psa
because
it's insane they're treating this as
though we're like back in the 50s and
60s when you know teachers are telling
kids to go under your desk and you'll be
protected from a nuclear attack it's
crazy the reality is president biden
members of congress leaders in our
country the wealthy they will have a
safe place to be in the event of a
nuclear
war that they are behind causing while
the rest of us in in america and russia
people around the world will be
decimated from this event and yet they
treat it as though it's nothing it's
nothing to take seriously they've been
making plans on how they can continue to
wage this war from an underground bunker
this is the seriousness of the threat
that we face and and how crazy and
disturbing it is that president biden
and people in his administration can be
so nonchalant about how they are the
ones who are continuing to drive this
forward cavalier exactly
tonight the new york times tulsi is
reporting that
ukrainians say they need faster
shipments of long-range artillery and
other uh sophisticated weapons to blunt
russia's steady advance
so the pentagon now is concerned about
potentially depleting
our stockpiles in the coming months so
the word depletion
is just becoming too common for
americans to hear these days our
finances are being depleted our weapons
are being depleted our artillery
stockpiles our oil is being depleted
from the strategic petroleum reserves
our spirit is being depleted by this
administration
yeah
you're completely right and that's where
this trip that president biden is taking
now he'll soon be going to saudi arabia
really exposes what a complete farce his
whole autocracy versus democracy foreign
policy is he's saying hey we've got to
go and get help to wage war against
russia
and in order to save quote-unquote
democracy and i'm gonna go talk to a
bunch of of autocratic dictators and ask
them for oil and ask them for help to be
able to do it we see that with saudi
arabia an islamist autocracy we see that
with turkey uh another guy who wants to
be caliph of his own new um you know
caliphate and ottoman empire who's
guilty of genocide against the kurds
they're it it is it is uh
a sham it is a lie that the american
people need to see
straight through and hold leaders
accountable for that lie and for the
cost that they are bringing on to the
american people and frankly to the world
the further they escalate this war yeah
muhammad bin bonesaw is going to demand
a lot for any oil that he gives us but i
bet he gives us nothing he's going to be
like the godfather how's nothing sound
to you that's what's that's what he's
going to do
tulsi it's great to see you tonight as
always hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else